service public service gagnant le
tournoi de roland garros s'est ouvert ce
matin le cours qualifier nos acision ans
et ont tous les matchs france qui par
antenne 2 fr3 direct sur le central dans
quelques minutes
quatre-vingt-dix mille dollars pour une
faute d'arbitrage volontaire après la
défaite de l'om contre le benfica en
tout cas sa petite contre attaque l'uefa
enquête prouve le sérieux en arménie
panique avant la hausse des prix à
moscou mirail l'abattoir fois localement
et signant la tempête
enfin situation toujours très tendue à
port gentil au gabon la production
pétrolière est désolé les troupes
françaises contrôlent les points
stratégiques reportage d'une variété
bonsoir le tennis en direct sur l'a3
yannick noah a semblé tout à l'heure à
19h en légère difficulté mais vous
sembliez tout de même optimiste michel
dhrey whipple optimiste puisque yannick
noah a remporté difficilement la
troisième manche il ment il mène donc 2
sets à 1 mais il faut dire que ce jeune
espagnol issu des qualifications francis
coquelin dray qui est né à ras aran
ouais c'est bien nous offre en ce moment
un jeudi concerto puisqu'il mène 1-0
dans ce quatrième set et que yannick
noah qui semble très très très éprouvés
en ce moment a bien du mal à gagner son
service il al'avantage pour l'instant
yannick noah qui a du mal égalité entre
les deux hommes
yannick noah qui a du mal à se déplacer
alors qu'en face ce jeune espagnol a un
tennis presque parfait c'est vrai qu'il
n'a rien à perdre
il joue bien dans ses relances dans son
service sur son revers sur son coup
droit est lui à 22 ans a bien envie de
créer la surprise
mais pour l'instant rien ni cnoa que
l'on va suivre au service ici première
balle qui ne passe pas c'est aussi l'un
des problèmes de yannick que ce soir une
première base du service qui a du mal à
franchir le filet deuxième service
yannick noah face à francisco clavé
voyez pas du tout toujours en retard sur
procès balle bien difficile pour
l'instant lea michele n'hésitez pas à
nous appeler au cours de ce journal où
l'on fera un résumé complet de la
journée avec notamment la victoire de
leconte et si le match joué par noah
n'est pas terminée à 19h57 la 3 prendra
le relais de la 2 et le diffusera
évidemment en direct michael gorbatchev
en proie à de nouvelles difficultés de
graves difficultés en arménie tout
d'abord où un affrontement meurtre
et a opposé des soldats soviétiques à
des militants arméniens le bilan est
très lourd au moins 20 morts et 45
blessés lors de ce week-end meurtrier en
ce moment même des centaines de milliers
de personnes manifestent à erevan pour
commémorer la journée anniversaire de
l'indépendance arménienne une
manifestation qui pourrait elle aussi
mal tourné hélène risacher menaces de
guerre civile en uc boutique par trois
fois en juillet et nationaliste arménien
a et les soldats soviétiques en
patrouille se sont affrontés violemment
fusillade dans le hall de la gare à
erevan puis dans la banlieue sud de la
capitale
et ce matin devant le siège du mouvement
national arménien le principal mouvement
indépendantiste de la république
plus de 25 morts 45 blessés des deux
côtés et aussi dans la population civile
selon moscou les nationalistes arméniens
chercher des armes dans cette tension
extrême les cérémonies anniversaire de
l'indépendance arménienne de 1918 avant
l'annexion soviétique de 1920 ces
cérémonies ont été réduites 80 mille
personnes ont participé à une
manifestation à erevan tout à l'heure
mais le mouvement national arménien a
renoncé au cortège vers le cimetière des
héros indépendantiste le mouvement
nationaliste parle de provocation des
militaires menant à la guerre civile
il lance un appel au calme dans la
population parce que des incidents plus
graves peuvent se produire à moscou les
autorités soviétiques dénonce les
attaques provocatrices des extrémistes
arméniens
ces heurts sanglants se sont produits au
lendemain d'une manifestation samedi à
erevan
une dizaine de milliers de personnes ont
appelé à la lutte contre l'armée et la
police soviétique
les forces de l'ordre envoyés par moscou
au début de l'année après les
affrontements interethniques entre
arméniens et azéris dans le caucase
confronté aux graves troubles en arménie
mirail gorbatchev doit aussi faire face
au vent de panique qui s'est emparée des
soviétiques à l'annoncé de la hausse des
prix à moscou foulée magasins ont été
pris d'assaut et dévalisées et il a
fallu que le numéro un soviétique
interviennent lui même à la télévision
mirel gorbatchev très pédagogue a
déclaré ne paniquez pas camarade gilles
du jour c'est oui mais ni la hausse du
prix du pain est une nécessité son prix
actuel ne correspond pas du tout à la
quantité de travail nécessaire à sa
production
hier soir au cours d'un long plaidoyer
télévisée de 50 minutes
hirai berbatov s'est voulu pédagogue
mais ferme pour tenter d'enrayer la
panique qui s'est emparée du pays ce
week-end
après l'annoncé la semaine dernière de
prochaines hausses de prix en l'espace
de deux jours un vent de folie s'est
abattue à moscou à peine le premier
ministre nicolas risk of avait-il
annoncé jeudi au parlement sa réforme
économique que les magasins d'état a été
pris d'assaut
personne n'a prêté la moindre attention
au fait que seul le prix du pain à les
tripes et au 1er juillet ni aux
assurances du kremlin selon lequel cette
hausse et celles à venir au début de
l'année prochaine serait compensée par
des allocations en fait tout le monde en
a déduit que tout allait augmenter le
lait la viande l'huile les pâtes
la mairie de moscou a tenté de réagir en
décidant de limiter la vente de produits
alimentaires aux seuls habitants de la
capitale à partir d'aujourd'hui donc
sans permis de résidence la porte des
magasins restera irrémédiablement fermé
aux milliers de soviétiques qui viennent
chaque jour des régions avoisinantes
s'approvisionner dans la capitale en
produits introuvables dans leur magasin
depuis des lustres
la mairie envisage également
d'introduire un rationnement quasi
générale actuellement seul le sucre est
rationné à moscou un attentat meurtrier
s'est produit aujourd'hui à jérusalem
sera marché en plein centre de la ville
un homme de 72 ans a été tué et neuf
autres personnes ont été blessées et
parmi elles trois enfants qui sont
toujours à l'hôpital
c'est le jihad islamique qui a commis
cet attentat en réponse aux massacres de
rishon le zion et cela va aggraver
considérablement les relations déjà
tendues entre les deux communautés juive
et musulmane de la ville de jérusalem
quant aux mouvements palestiniens des
territoires occupés leur leader
poursuivre leur grève de la faim
reportage clément weill raynal et de
pierre michel
depuis une semaine les territoires
occupés sont sous couvre feu c'est donc
à jérusalem que les leaders palestiniens
de l'intifada ont décidé d'entreprendre
une grève de la faim pour demander
publiquement l'envoi de casques bleus en
cisjordanie et à gaza l'israélien il
n'en est pas question selon jérusalem
la présence permanente des soldats de
l'onu ne ferait qu'encourager les actes
de violence installé depuis plusieurs
jours dans les jardins de la croix rouge
les grévistes de la faim sont sous
protection internationale
la police israélienne ne peut intervenir
malgré les chants et les slogans en
faveur de l'ol paie cette grève de la
faim est une manifestation pacifique
explique fayçal rousset ni l'un des
principaux chefs de l'intifada mais si
l'on ne nous écoute pas nous craignons
une nouvelle explosion dans les
territoires bien plus forte que les
précédentes
certains leader de l'intifada pense déjà
qu'il faut modifier notre stratégie
en attendant les jardins de la croix
rouge sont devenus le point de passage
obligé de tous les notables palestiniens
toute la journée des députés arabes des
maires des prêtres et des universitaires
viennent saluer les grévistes cette
manifestation est destinée à attirer
l'attention sur la situation dans les
territoires occupés mais pour les
palestiniens il s'agit aussi d'un
événement c'est la première fois que les
notables palestiniens viennent faire
publiquement acte d'allégeance devant
les chefs de l'intifada réunis à
jérusalem
pas d'inquiétude pour les français qui
sont restés au gabon des mesures de
sécurité ont été prises mais la
situation reste très tendue à port
gentil la production pétrolière et par
pratiquement stoppé après le départ des
techniciens européens l'activité
économique et donc ralenti tout le pays
et dans la tente d'une importante
déclarations d'omar bongo alors que
l'opposition reste mobilisée
particulièrement à port-gentil reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux
pierre babey et patrick mille herriot
chaque soir dans ce quartier sud de port
gentil les démonstrations de deuil à la
mémoire de l'opposant
joseph rendjambé prennent une tournure
très politique de manifestations contre
le régime d'omar bongo à la tête du
mouvement de contestation
un parti d'opposition le pdp parti
gabonais du progrès ça va parce que la
france les hommes de bons modèles dans
le reste de port gentil les rues ont
retrouvé leur calme après les pillages
les scènes d'émeutes des derniers jours
le consulat de france est gardé par les
légionnaires on y fait le bilan des
dégâts au large de port gentil les
plates formes d'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures
ici le départ des compagnies pétrolières
est ressentie comme un lâchage du régime
d'omar bongo
mais le général gabonais dépêchés sur
place pour rétablir l'ordre a pour
consigne extrême d'éviter à tout prix
les affrontements apparemment tout ancré
dans la le couvre-feu respecter pour le
faire respecter vos émissions de
rétablir l'ordre par tous les moyens à
tous les moyens d'abord de moyens
pacifiques
en ce lundi la situation est plutôt
calme dans les rues tant à libreville
qu'à port-gentil mais l'activité
économique est considérablement ralentie
chacun ici attend une importante
déclaration gouvernementale qui
devraient renouer le dialogue
au gabon le téléphone n'a fonctionné
aujourd'hui dans les états majors des
partis de l'opposition les chefs werther
de l'idée
hésitent toujours à se rendre à la table
ronde sur l'immigration organisée par
michel rocard elle aura lieu demain à
17h30
seuls les centristes ont donné leur
accord alors les migrations en question
tout de suite un exemple d'un organisme
de contrôle dont les pouvoirs ont été
renforcés l'année dernière l'ofpra
l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides bénéficie depuis
décembre dernier de crédits
supplémentaires
résultat une plus grande rapidité
d'action et un contrôle plus serré des
délais passé en france mais peut-être
aussi quelques bavures reportage jean
marc pitte et bernard brengues la
situation d' étrangers en attente d'un
statut de réfugié présenté en france de
nombreux avantages
un permis de séjour temporaire et un
pécule de 1300 francs pour survivre cet
état intermédiaire pouvait durer
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
un laps de temps qui drainait vers cette
procédure des étrangers venus en france
pour des raisons plus économiques que
politiques ou religieuses l'année
dernière le gouvernement a décidé de
réagir en décembre 89
le budget de l'office français de
protection des réfugiés et apatrides à
tripler les effectifs sont augmentés le
traitement des dossiers informatisés et
l'on s'équipe même d'un fichier
d'empreintes digitales permettant de
repérer les tricheurs
auteur de plusieurs demandes simultanées
résultat le délai de réponse est
redescendu à 3 mois et l'efficacité
augmentant le nombre des demandes
farfelues à diminuer la procédure est
revenu assez qu'elle aurait dû toujours
être c'est-à-dire une procédure rapide
et qui est là pour faire le tri entre
des demandeurs d'asile fondé et de
demandeurs d'asile qui le sont moins et
nous constatons que la diminution des
demandeurs d'asile depuis six mois
montrent bien que cette politique
commence à porter des fruits
les fruits au goût amer pour certains
son nouvel objectif de célérité poussent
parfois le fera à rejeter des cas
critiques l'ont raté turc
c'est un des membres du parti communiste
révolutionnaire de son pays
à 32 ans cet engagement lui a déjà valu
dix années de prison et quelques séances
de torture sa demande d'asile a pourtant
été refusée faute de preuves
le droit d'asile en france perd de plus
en plus de sa valeur
le gouvernement se ferme à ce droit et
aux réfugiés le traitement des dossiers
par le frappe et souvent inégale et dans
mon cas il est injuste le dossier de
mourad doit encore passer devant la
commission des recours si l'asie lui est
une nouvelle fois refusé il ne pourra
que chercher un autre pays d'accueil
car pour lui le retour en turquie est
synonyme de prison ou pire
prudence prudence nous vous annoncions
la semaine dernière une agression
raciste contre une jeune fille noire
d'avignon mais la jeune fille avait tout
inventé
la jeune fille avait affirmé que quatre
hommes l'avaient agressé en plein
centre-ville en proférant des injures
racistes avant de l'atteindre
partiellement ce soir le procureur de la
république dément formellement cette
version l'écoutent
la mineure en cause à fabuler elle a
invoqué une agression à caractère
raciste pour justifier expliquer auprès
de ses parents une le résultat
malheureux d'une une séance me priver de
deux coiffeurs de coupe de cheveux à
laquelle elle a participé volontiers
avec des camarades du camarade de place
et l'on retrouve michel dhrey à roland
garros où yannick noah est peut-être en
train de perdre le quatrième set michel
exactement paul meilhat dictant en très
grosse difficultés il ya eu une vraie
qui n'avance plus et qui est menée
écoutez bien 5 0 dans le quatrième set
c'est à dire qu'on va sûrement avoir
droit à une cinquième manche en revanche
une bonne nouvelle nathalie tauziat
monsieur qualifié en battant
l'australienne goodrich six fois et
c'est un tournoi n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
et on vous retrouve michel dans quelques
minutes pour la fin peut-être de ce
quatrième set et je vous rappelle que
l'on diffusera le cinquième set sur l'a3
tout à l'heure rester avec nous
cowboy ou gardien de square les
policiers municipaux balance souvent
entre ces deux images aussi caricaturale
l'une que l'autre la réalité c'est que
de nombreux policiers des études même
pas à circuler en ville avec une arme et
cela pose un problème à la police
nationale sur la question de les
désarmer
béatrice nivois à pied à cheval en
voiture ou en moto les policiers
municipaux sont dix mille en france
employés par quelques 2700 communes
armée 37% d'entre eux le sont notamment
à cannes ou à nice à amiens par exemple
ils n'ont que des menottes pour quelles
missions surveiller prévenir la petite
délinquance constater les infractions
depuis de nombreuses années on cherche
aux polices municipales un véritable
statut le rapport clauzel rendu public
aujourd'hui propose un certain nombre de
mesures
un recrutement assurée par concours une
formation dans le cadre du centre
national de la fonction publique et à
terme la suppression du port d'armes
pour les policiers municipaux
une proposition accueillie favorablement
par le ministre de l'intérieur en france
d'habitude est différente france les
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
obtenue en tout cas portent toujours les
normales et que ça fait presque partie
de l'uniforme
est-ce que c'est indispensable je suis
convaincu que non et donc à cet égard
mon point de vue est beaucoup plus large
encore poursuivre monsieur clauzel qui
parle la police municipale je pense
qu'il n'est pas indispensable que tous
les policiers soient armés c'est en
juillet que pierre joxe rencontrera
l'association des maires de france et
les différentes organisations syndicales
de la police municipale pour discuter
d'un projet de loi de suite les autres
faits marquants de l'actualité en france
jean-françois grégoire
brebis d'un côté gaz lacrymogènes de
l'ordre 400 producteurs on va ont tenté
de pénétrer à l'intérieur de la
préfecture d'albi ce matin ils se sont
violemment heurtés aux forces de police
des éleveurs s'inquiètent de la chute
des cours et demain il devrait être un
millier à manifester leur crâne dans la
capitale six relaxes et cette peine de
huit à quinze mois de prison pour les
mutas de la plaisance un mort le
tribunal correctionnel de châteauroux
vient de rendre son verdict en novembre
87 13 détenus avaient retenu plusieurs
personnes en otages pendant une nuit au
cours de la mutinerie un incendie avait
en partie détruit la prison un auteur a
été abattu par avoir accouché un village
de picardie le notaire devait effectuer
des relevés de cadastre mais un retraité
qui pensait être face à un malfaiteur
l'a tué avec un fusil de chasse
si elle découvert pour les voyageurs
suite à la grève des contrôleurs aériens
du centre régional d'accueil semences
dans les stones le trafic des aéroports
parisiens a diminué de moitié et cinq
villes de province n'ont pas du tout été
relié à la capitale paris ajaccio bastia
c'est le tiercé des villes les plus
chères de france selon un rapport publié
par l'insee
à l'opposé caen nantes et poitiers
remporté la palme des villes les moins
chères
moralité si vous êtes fauché fuyaient la
ville lumière luit de beauté et
choisissez l'ouest de la france
y at il une mafia des arbitres on peut
se poser la question après le scandale
révélé par nos confrères de l'équipe
aujourd'hui plusieurs arbitres
pousserait est en effet régulièrement
des sommes allant de 500 à 600 mille
francs par match pour oublier deux mois
entre guillemets ou de sanctionner des
fautes on pense bien sûr au match om
benfica en coupe d'europe
il y a quelques semaines didier balès 18
avril demi finale retour benfica om la
main de vata qualifie les portugais et
déclenché une polémique
c'est tout d'abord la presse portugaise
qui fait écho d'une déclaration de silva
resende responsable à l'uefa des
problèmes communautaires
bernard tapie aurait démonter les
rouages d'une filière frauduleuse de
corruption d'arbitrés dès le 8 mai le
système consisterait à récupérer
l'argent offert aux arbitres
plusieurs transferts entre banques
suisses atterrirait à la banque edmond
de rothschild là un listing de comptes
codé serait gérée par les intermédiaires
mis en cause l'arbitré belge monsieur
langenhove a fermement nié aujourd'hui
être impliqué dans une affaire de
corruption
il a cependant reconnu avoir arbitré
fréquemment les portugais et souhaite
que l'enquêté aille à son terme cet
après midi l'om et son président ne
souhaitait apporter aucun commentaire
même si l'on espère que les
investigations vont se poursuivre côté
uefa le porte parole précise que les
soupçons porterait sur d'autres
rencontres jouées par des clubs
portugais
si les sommes en jeu de l'ordre de 600
mille francs ne semble pas toucher les
arbitres français
la lumière doit impérativement être fait
sous peine de discréditer l'ensemble des
compétitions européennes
yannick noah est en train de souffrir à
roland garros on va y retourner dans
quelques instants en direct mais henri
leconte lui a gagné c'est l'une des
images du jour et du résumé proposé par
caroline since et jean philippe djian
premiers pas de le pont devant un public
qu'il doit reconquérir depuis sa finale
en 88 l'haïtien ronald agenor quart de
finaliste ici l'an dernier n'est pas
mince adversaires et dès le début du
premier set agenor impressionne en
menant 4 jeux à 1
mais le conte sort de sa torpeur et
aligne cinq jeux de suite avant de
remporter cette première manche 6 4
henry est désormais lancée et rien ne
peut l'arrêter
le deuxième et le troisième set un
véritable festival au filet les volets
françaises auront raison des coups droit
haïtien 6 2 6 4
un seul petit tube ingénieurs à paris
prochain adversaire de leconte le
yougoslave aurait zares
premier test pour michael chang 18 ans
tenant du titre opposé au brésilien
cascio motta 30 ans l'un des vétérans du
circuit
chang qui a dû subir une infiltration
dans la jambe avant de jouer s'impose
assez facilement en trois sets 6-2 7-6
6-1 alors dieu sur est il de nouveau à
ses côtés roland garros de près t-il
lebel argentin alberto mancini en baisse
de forme ces derniers temps il a éliminé
aujourd'hui la tête de série numéro 9
l'américain geiberger en trois sets 6 4
6 2 6 2 il pourrait retrouver le conte
en huitièmes de finale la plus belle
résistance du jour celle de la française
isabelle demongeot
après avoir perdu le premier set 6 0
face à la tchécoslovaque jana novotna
elle gagne le deuxième au tie break
novotna 15e joueuse mondiale est obligé
de se bagarrer pour gagner le troisième
set 18 une défaite française avec tous
les honneurs
51e match à roland garros pour yannick
noah maintenant 26e mondial passe un
jeune espagnol de 21 ans entre cisco
clavé noah hargneux et ont 10 ans
réussit un coup superbe et fait rugir le
central de plaisir fin de ce 19 ans plus
tôt que prévu à cause du tennis le 19
ans offrent généreusement ses minutes au
service des sports de la iii qui va vous
permettre dans quelques secondes de
suivre en direct la fin du match joué
par yannick noah qui est en difficulté
mais le programme ce soir ne sera pas
pour autant bouleverser pas du tout
faits le programme sur l'a3 ce soir
marius le premier film de la trilogie de
pagnol avec notamment raimu et pierre
fresnay prochain rendez vous avec l'info
c'est à 22h45 soir 3 présenté par marc
hautement en quelques secondes
yannick noah et michèle rey en direct
sur l'a3 pour la fin du match joué par
noah à demain 19h bonsoir bonsoir
pour nous